[Musique]
nous sommes le 22 septembre merci de
nous rejoindre pour cette nouvelle
édition du 7 8 elle est invitée et voici
justement les invités du jour béatrice
d'âgés docteur au centre hospitalier de
plaisir elle reviendra sur l'importance
d'être à l'écouté de l'entourage des
patients atteints par la maladie
d'alzheimer neuf cent mille personnes en
souffrent 2 millions d'aidants sont
concernés valérie ferrer en charge du
tourisme d'affaires à
saint-quentin-en-yvelines nous verrons
avec l comment s'est déroulée
l'opération de démonstration du vélo à
assistance électrique c'est hier à
montigny le bretonneux dans le cadre de
la semaine de la mobilité et puis le
marquis henri-françois de breteuil
reviendra sur la programmation de son
château pour cet automne dès ce week end
les visiteurs découvriront un spectacle
d'escrimé artistique nous ferons
également avec lui un point sur la
fréquentation des derniers mois nous
commençons par une problématique de
santé il n'existe toujours pas de
traitements qui permettent d'en guérir
ou d'en modifier efficacement
l'évolution alzheimer touche près d'un
million de personnes en france pour
l'entourage pour les aidants de
nombreuses incertitudes et également
d'inquiétude au quotidien à l'occasion
ir mercredi de la journée mondiale
consacrée à cette maladie les
spécialistes sont intervenus pour
informer et soutenir également l les
aidants écoutez donc le docteur béatrice
taj est psychiatre pour les
consultations mémoire de l'hôpital de
jour à plaisir c'est au micro de corinne
fallait cette journée l'intérêt c'est de
parler des aidants les aidants familiaux
en particulier
donc c'est une population en fait qui
est
très sensible et très vulnérable et
c'est grâce à aux aidants familiaux que
les patients peuvent rester le plus
longtemps possible chez eux pendant
cette journée les aidants vont pouvoir
découvrir ce qu'on fait à l'hôpital de à
l'hôpital de plaisir dans cette filière
de psychogériatrie en particulier aux
consultations
à l'hôpital deux jours ainsi qu'à
l'unité dali la consultation mémoire est
une est un moment également où on prend
en compte on écoute les dents et où on
recherche les facteurs d'épuisement de
les dents pour pouvoir après à trouver
des solutions adaptées
les facteurs d'épuisement c'est surtout
les allemands les conflits le déni de la
maladie de leur proche par exemple les
troubles du comportement de leurs
proches la restriction de vie
personnelle ça ce sont les facteurs
principaux d'épuisement de l'aidant et
c'est pendant la consultation est même
tout au long de la prise en charge du
patient que l'on peut
évaluer ces facteurs les rechercher et
trouver des solutions ensemble les deux
tiers des patients vivent à domicile
dont un tiers quand même dans un état
dans une
état sévère quand même donc beaucoup à
domicile et donc c'est les aidants c'est
grâce aux aidants qui peuvent rester à
domicile c'est la famille qui les
entoure et leur rôle et ben c'est
de pouvoir les aider dans le quotidien
dans les tâches quotidiennes les
soutenir
voilà c'est les aider quand fait dans
les tâches quotidiennes un malade qui
est soutenu ça change beaucoup mais un
malade un aidant qui est soutenu ça
change beaucoup parce que a directement
ça
ça joue sur le patient il est nécessaire
de prendre en compte tous les besoins et
les attentes des aidants pour qu'ils
puissent faire face ensuite aux
difficultés de leurs proches et pour que
la leur qualité de vie soit meilleur la
qualité de vie de l'aidant et aussi du
patient
nous poursuivons avec la semaine de la
mobilité qui se poursuit jusqu'au à 23
septembre et dans ce cadre les
transports en commun les circulations
douces sont mis en avant a mises en
avant par don à saint quentin en
yvelines la ferme du manet vient
d'accueillir les professionnels du
tourisme pour des tests de vélos à
assistance électrique valérie ferrer
chargé du tourisme à saint quentin en
yvelines elles nous ont dit plus du
tourisme d'affaires à 50 ans interview
menée par camille lambert
nous sommes à la ferme du manet de
montigny le bretonneux où les
professionnels du tourisme et les
entrepreneurs sont invités à tester les
vélos à assistance électrique avec nous
valérie ferrer en charge du tourisme
d'affaires à saint quentin en yvelines
pour nous parler de cet événement
bonjour valérie bonjour alors tout
d'abord si vous pouvez nous expliquer
quel est cet événement à qui s'adresse
et pourquoi l'avoir organisée alors nous
sommes dans le cadre de la semaine de la
mobilité la semaine européenne de la
mobilité donc la communauté
d'agglomération souhaite fédérer les
partenaires autour des enjeux de l'éco
mobilité et bien sûr les hôteliers font
partie des professionnels qui peuvent
aussi adhéré à ce à ce processus
notamment par la présentation en live de
l'offre en terme de vélos électriques
donc c'est pour ça qu'on a souhaité
effectivement que les professionnels du
territoire soit là pour pouvoir tester
et puis adapté
adapter leurs demandes en fonction des
offres aussi qui sont disponibles sur le
territoire alors ce vélo à assistance
électrique qu'est-ce que ça collait
différence avec un vélo classique poutre
plus traditionnelle alors je l'essayé
tout à l'heure je n'avais jamais essayé
c'est bon c'est pareil on fait du vélo
de la même façon sauf que c'est beaucoup
plus facile et on a l'impression d'une
sensation de liberté de facilité qui est
assez assez bluffante et puis on peut
aller beaucoup plus loin donc ça c'est
c'est vraiment l'avantagent principal
c'est peut-être moi sportif quoique si
on fait beaucoup de kilomètres même si
on applique là comme une brute c'est
quand même c'est quand même sportif
finalement et voilà c'est une
alternative aux déplacements donc c'est
aussi bien loisirs que professionnel y
en a qui utilisent vraiment les vélos
électriques pour comme moyen de
locomotion quotidien pour leurs
déplacements domicile travail en fait
ces vélos à assistance électrique qu'ils
ont croisé dans une batterie ça on
installé sur le vélo voilà c'est ça
effectivement alors la batterie à l'est
soit escamotable soit pas soit fixe il
ya différentes solutions proposées avec
des stations vélos ou la ce le vélo se
recharge sur la station il n'y a pas
besoin d'aller le brancher
indépendamment et puis toutes sortes de
vélos triporteurs voilà tout et tout et
adaptable et tout est modulable selon
les envies les désirs des clientèles
alors ici du coup sont présentés trois
partenaires qui sont ils alors nous
avons néo velec qui est un partenaire
qui est présent sur magny les hameaux
qui s'adresse beaucoup à une clientèle
individuelle aussi
qui a une boutique qui s'appelle la
maison du vélo à magny les hameaux et
qui l' offre vraiment une gamme assez
large de vélo ensuite nous avons pris
note qui travaille sur la france entière
mais qui est présent sur saint quentin
en yvelines et qui travaille auprès des
sociétés notamment et des territoires
pour mettre en place des stations vélos
ou là effectivement on est dans du vélo
partage c'est un peu comme du vélib mais
électrique et puis nous avons colibri
qui travaille aussi sur le territoire et
qui travaille spécifiquement avec les
entreprises est alors maintenant vieux
pour avoir discuté avec les hôteliers
qui sont qui sont passés sur l'événement
ils me disent que leur clientèle est
vraiment en demande maintenant de ce
service supplémentaire qui correspond
vraiment à une démarche innovante
voilà une démarche qualité aussi c'est à
dire que les hôteliers sont toujours à
la recherche de voix là de montrer que
leurs prestations sont de qualité donc
on allie qualité
écologie et puis le fun entre guillemets
c'est à dire que les clientèles comme je
vous le disais de jeunes générations
sont plus enclines enclin à ce genre de
vélo et l'éco mobilité c'est important
aujourd'hui de la promouvoir d'en parler
ça me paraît indispensable c'est un
enjeu environnemental
de base donc oui c'est je regrette même
qu'on en soit que là c'est un peu c'est
un peu on a encore on est un petit peu
en retard par rapport à certains pays
notamment on peut imaginer des solutions
je pense pour pour aller plus loin dans
la démarche
on m'a très bien merci beaucoup valérie
ferrer merci
je reçois à présent en plateau
henri-françois de bretagne le marquis de
breteuil bonsoir on soigne en plateau
aujourd'hui votre château accueille cent
mille visiteurs par an pour arriver à ce
chiffre vous multipliez elle les
animations en marge des différentes
visites et pour ce premier week-end
d'automne vous proposait notamment un
spectacle de cape et d'épée qui mêle
intrigue rebondissements trahison et
aventure vous nous en dit un petit peu
plus bien sûr c'est une compagnie qui
s'appelle les lames sur seine qui est
basée dans notre région fait à la région
ile de france à neuilly et leur patron
en quelque sort le maître d'armes c'est
michel ollivier qui a été trois fois
champion du monde d'escrimé artistique
alors il s'agit donc d'avoir des duels
mais de décrire ses duels dans une sorte
de théâtre en quelque sorte et des
scènes des 3 mousquetaires qu'on va
reproduire justement en créant les duels
de au moment où il ya des duels dans le
roman de dumas donc ça beaucoup de
beaucoup de panache beaucoup de succès
nous allons accueillir une trentaine de
membres de la compagnie ce dimanche et
l'après midi ce sera le concert le matin
ils feront des exercices eto'o et la
prime tout l'après midi il y aura ce
spectacle à partir de 3h30 c'est
important pour vous enseigner ces
moments de scène vivante pour pour le
public qui vient visiter le château
c'était essentiel je crois que un
château il faut qu'il se passe toujours
quelque chose comme on dit pour d'autres
endroits et c'est une manière de faire
revenir le public on a un public et
applique de famille parents et enfants
essentiellement c'est le cas sur les
cent mille visiteurs qui viennent il ya
beaucoup d'enfants aussi des écoles qui
viennent en semaine beaucoup de
scolaires mais il faut donner plus et
puis au fond je dirais il faut que la
quand la réalité rejoint la fiction
c'est à dire les mousquetaires ils ont
été à breteuil breton est un château
d'époque louis xiii ils y sont venus pas
cela mais d'autres et au fond on a eu
des aïeux qui arrêtait mousquetaires du
roi donc retrouver les mousquetaires en
chair et en os le truc c'est bien c'est
une sorte de manière d'évoquer
l'histoire de manière très vivante sur
les prochains mois vous mettez aussi à
l'honneur les comptes c'est une
opération qui a débuté déjà lors des
précédentes saisons et à chaque saison
une série de contes oui alors chaque
saison une série différente cette année
pour l'automne tous les dimanches du 2
du pardon pas du dehors du neuf du 16 et
du 23 nous avons les comptes du goût qui
accompagneront les contes de perrault il
ya toujours au moins un conte de
perrault deux contes de perrault est un
conte spécialisée dans la période donc
là comme c'est la grande semaine du goût
qui arrive on aura le 9 le 16 et le 23
les comptes du goût et puis le 2 nous
aurons du théâtre autour des contes avec
la compagnie du crâne a animé par
christophe leray là on va montrer des
petites pièces autour du petit chaperon
rouge nous restons fidèle au conte et
enfin le 30 octobre pour la clôture du
mois ce seront les grenadiers de
napoléon qui vont défiler ils ont une
centaine ils vont défiler faire des
manoeuvres tirer au canon sens j'espère
blessés les visiteurs rassurez vous il
ne les inquiétait pas parce que les
visiteurs en plus ils sont plutôt
nombreux lorsqu on discutait avant le
début de cet entretien vous me disait
que la période estivale s'était plutôt
bien passé pour votre établissement ce
qui n'a pas été le cas pour le tourisme
dans son ensemble en france et même dans
le département alors nous avons la
chance d'avoir un public fidèle qui est
un public de la région un public de
familles de parents et d'enfants et je
le vois chaque départ de visite puisque
jacques et moi même des visiteurs tous
les jours pendant les vacances et tous
les dimanches tous les samedis de
l'année et je vois qu'on a un public qui
est essentiellement je dirais pour les
les deux tiers vraiment le public des
week-ends ces sont des parents
accompagnés d'enfants je crois qu'on est
le château qui a créé le plus d'enfants
en proportion puisque sur les cent mille
visiteurs il ya au moins cinquante mille
enfants c'est-à-dire un sur deux mais du
coup nous ne sommes pas frappé par la
baisse des grands nos grands frères
comme versailles parce que là
heureux raisonnée beaucoup et à juste
titre sur les mouvements internationaux
la chine le japon les états unis qui eux
sont venus beaucoup moins nombreux et au
contraire je dirais que les petits
châteaux comme breteuil les moyens
château honte et bénéficier de ce regard
qu'ont porté vers un monument plus la
campagne vis-à-vis des grands monuments
prestigieux qui eux perdaient des
étrangers vous avez dû adapter malgré
tout les mesures de sécurité sur le site
je vous avouerai que en dehors de
l'observation que font nos guides à
l'arrivée nous ne faisons pas de mesures
de sécurité particulières contrairement
aux monuments d'état nous avons bien sûr
des systèmes d'alarmé pour toutes les
collections mais on quand on est à sac
un peu suspect on le regarde
éventuellement on cherche pas du tout
affolé nos visiteurs vous vous êtes
battus pour conserver cette bâtisse qui
est familiale on a eu l'occasion d'en
parler plus d'une fois sur cette antenne
aujourd'hui la fréquentation se porte
plutôt bien mais vous êtes toujours très
impliqué est ce que vous êtes serein
confiant pour l'avenir oui je suis
confiant dans la mesure où un château
finalement comme breteuil il est en
dehors des modes puis laisser quelque
chose de permanent avec l'évocation de
l'histoire puisque au fond on recherche
beaucoup l'histoire de la france de
manière très vivante c'est le cas avec
la nature et les jardins avec les contes
de perrault donc je suis confiant je
vois que cette année par exemple au 31
août nous étions à +6 5% on va peut-être
atteindre les 110 milles payants cette
année ayant si tout se passe bien si la
météo qui joue un grand rôle est bonne à
l'automne et je suis con lui je suis de
nenad d'une nature optimiste et
confiante pour le tourisme culturel en
général et pour le château de breteuil
certains bretons qui accueille donc ce
spectacle véritable spectacle des scream
dès ce week end et puis il ya d'autres
manifestations a évoqué les comptes il y
en aura d'autres sur toute la saison
d'automne telcité un autre rendez vous
rapidement alors on peut citer les camps
du goût et surtout le 30 octobre les
grenadiers de napoléon qui seront
présents et qui font des manoeuvres pour
le grand public merci henri françois de
bretagne marquis de breteuil c'est la
fin de cette édition du 7 8 les invité à
voir en replay sur notre site internet
les programmes qui se poursuivent sur tv
fier merci à vous
[Musique]